you tweeted three years ago
oh well
anyone who believes proof of stake can
work is either one completely clueless
at how and why bitcoin works at all or
two a con artist using it as a buzzword
to promote a worthless scam like
ethereum
do you still believe
that
ethereum
is a scam
and in general proof of stake you're
either clueless
if you think it's interesting
yeah no i still stand by that um i think
the uh would you classify a theorem as a
[ __ ] coin for sure it's the um it's the
mother [ __ ] from which the [ __ ] coins
spring
the royal the king bitcoin yeah
i think the key thing is uh you know the
way to think about there's another tweet
from a couple of years ago which is
essentially proof of work was like the
invention of flight like we've got in
this machine and we managed to get it to
fly off the ground and proof of stake is
hey
we found a great way to make airplanes
cheaper and faster by not making them
fly
by keeping them on the ground like the
the invention of proof-of-work the
reason the entire
digital currency space exists is because
bitcoin operates based on proof of work
if bitcoin was based on proof of stake
it would have died or been shut down
from day one but that's a hypothesis and
a lot of people believe that and i think
they have a lot of strong support but
basically
proof of work is is grounded in physics
in the real world the proof of stake is
more about is politics it's the federal
reserve it's exactly what we have it's
exactly what we have it's just a group
of people who get to decide the rules
and it's essentially a a system that is
you know it's a security it's a company
so it's not an innovation in any sense
it's a step backward to what we already
had which is you get a bunch of people
in charge of the money now the only
reason it survives in this uh
the reason i call these things scam and
i have no problem with calling them a
scam is because they fraudulently
present themselves as being
decentralized they present themselves as
just being a different way of doing
decentralization than bitcoin when it's
not it's just they're writing bitcoins
codetails and they're writing the fact
that most people don't quite understand
what bitcoin is and how it works to
portray themselves as a cheaper better
more more efficient way of doing what
bitcoin does it's not it's a less
legally accountable way of doing what
central banks do
right so and the basic criticism is that
there's a group of people sometimes a
very small group of people that can
control the parameters
of the operation of the system so over
time
you can't trust
it's not gold under the mattress it
doesn't have that kind of heart it's not
property and i
really very strongly recommend your
discussion with sailor for people who
want to elaborate more on this there's a
bunch of people in charge which means
that
um you know legally they should be doing
this under securities law um but even as
an anarchist if i don't want to care
about that
the technical implication of it is this
is never going to be adopted as a
neutral way of transferring value on the
internet because
we you need something that enemies can
trade with one another you can't have
something that has a small group of
people in charge because a the small
group of people themselves can be
corrupted and b
they can be coerced you know you can put
a bunch of people in a room put a gun to
their head and
um you can change everything in any of
these digital currencies and that's why
that's why i think you know you'll find
a lot more sympathy among theaters to uh
[ __ ] coins the keynesian economist to
ethereum fanboy pipeline is a very
strong one because
it it's uh the same thing it's like you
like the idea of people being in charge
in money and you think you're going to
be the one who's going to be in charge
of money so you see a lot of this
phenomena and you see the same people
that want gold and don't like central
banking they get into bitcoin yeah so
just to actually
push back on a couple of things so one
is fiature it sounds like i'm trying to
be a sophisticated brit talking about
theater but uh
for many reasons it's not making me feel
good about that uh so
you know day by day things change you
used to be one of those
uh so people evolve people learn people
that are supportive of bitcoin might
eventually become supporters
of ethereum or go back to supporting
fiat we don't know people evolve for
different reasons you grow up you mature
or you uh become enlightened so i think
every single person sort of
as this technology is evolving as this
world is evolving
as wars break on the geopolitics changes
the monetary system is constantly
put under stress people will evolve so
we're trying to all figure it out
together that's why i like
open-mindedness here i think
for people like me at least this seems
essential i know so i expect you to be
answering all the spam emails you get
i will prince by prince by friends but
no i
i don't have a clear understanding what
is a good investment of my time what is
the good investment in my money that's
that doesn't seem clear because things
um
things are good at promoting themselves
i'm not talking about all
the different kinds of things like
ethereum altcoins and so on i just mean
life like dating
jobs
um
friendships
like everybody's advertising themselves
is a great investment right um but you
don't you don't know and you have to
keep an open mind and also you know i
don't
um and be sort of self-introspective
about what um
how like biases i operate under
and uh ways i delude myself
like hallucinations that i'm living
under it's like breaking you know
breaking out of all these hallucinations
it's very hard to introspect
thinking like what are the assumptions
under which i lived my entire life that
might be actually false assumptions
that's a really
difficult uh thought process to take
it's a dangerous one it's you the
nietzsche if you gaze along into the
abyss the
biscuits into you it's like alex jones
i mean he's living
he's got demons in his head
so he has like the all these conspiracy
theories that it holds in his head but
it begins to really destroy him
so it's a psychological burden to to
carry so if you question
if you question authority if you
question government if you question
culture the way things have been done
it's really difficult
um and the biases you are operate under
it's really difficult to question them
so i think like being
constantly open-minded and self-critical
not constantly but a little bit every
day is important i think yeah but i mean
you know you're talking to somebody you
know i grew up in ramallah in palestine
in the west bank
i've
changed my mind on all kinds of
different things the fact that i was
even open to the idea of bitcoin is
required has required an enormous
enormous amount it's a heck of a journey
so
i'd much rather appreciate um you know
direct arguments rather than these kind
of general fluffy you know you should be
oh of course yes you should be
open-minded but you know also you come
up with conclusions and you delete spam
emails sometimes when you know that it
is spam because you have to move on with
your life you can't there's an
opportunity cost of considering every
spam email so well to me okay so i'll
i'll just say for my
relatively sort of shallow perspective
almost like a technical person mostly my
understanding of economics is weak
proof of stake is not obviously
weak consensus mechanism relative to
proof of work
so it's not that's not obvious to me
that that goes wrong and get becomes
corrupted in the way that governments
get corrupted because
it still
seems decentralized now your criticism
of governance is an interesting one but
if you put that aside it still is a
decentralized mechanism
and it's more transparent than the
mechanism
that governments operate it isn't it's
exactly what the federal reserve is the
federal reserve is a proof of stake
system the federal reserve is owned by
its constituent banks and so the rules
of the federal reserve and the
regulations are determined by the
ownership which is the banks so it's
exactly what the federal reserve is but
it's too back door the the agreements
between the the banks and the federal
reserve it feels like a lot of those
agreements are made between individuals
that
sort of behind the scenes it's not hard
to it's opaque yes but the only way that
a proof of stake system will take off is
if you have a military to force people
to use it
that's the thing ultimately there's no
way that it's going to take off on on a
free market and that's why
you know for all of the bluster about
wanting to move to a proof-of-stake
system ethereum have been saying this
since 2014 it's now been eight years you
know they've been talking about it
they we still haven't seen the proof of
stake system operational in the wild
it's vaporware for all practical things
proof of stake it's
potential i mean you can do it in a
centralized way but like
um
can it survive can it last for a long
time i don't think so and i think um you
know it it can last perhaps initially
with marketing with centralized
marketing you can promote it but
ultimately
user demand the people that are not
interested in speculating because they
want to get rich on this the people that
are going to use it they're going to
want to use it because they can
trust that it is not going to be messed
with yes so like but there's also
applications that house a lot lightning
network but there's applications on top
like well the reason i'm interested in
things like ethereum
is you might think it's ridiculous i
thought it was ridiculous but nfts
right so what's the you can have nfts
probably on top of bitcoin but you don't
because there's no marketing on in
bitcoin because
all these ideas get promoted on
proprietary [ __ ] coins because yes but
there's the network effects of ideas of
applications so they just take off for
some reason and human civilization is
such that you get excited about stuff
and large amounts of people believe a
thing and they start to get excited it
actually has impact like the fact that
nfts can have an impact on the art world
or the world in general
is is wild to me
but it it worked so well you know the
question is david rothko has an impact
on the art world doesn't say much i'm
saying these ideas have you know we're
collective intelligent beings and we can
believe a thing and that has
that has power that has led to major
wars and all those kinds of things so
the
uh it's interesting to me that nfts took
hold and the question is is there
distributed no adapts is there's
distributed apps built on top of
different blockchains that might somehow
transform the world you have to kind of
keep an open mind to that
uh because right now it's like uh it's
like i'm the same place with that as i
am with like virtual reality it's like
all right this seems like a really
intellectually promising
set of ideas here but there's something
either technically or socially not quite
taking hold why
and i don't know what the right answer
is so with virtual reality what's the
right answer is it just technically uh
the latency is is too high or
uh the games are not good enough or is
it a fundamentally flawed idea that you
can live in a virtual world and enjoy it
that the physical world is just orders
of magnitude better uh or uh a
two-dimensional display is just as good
as a three-dimensional world i don't
know why is virtual reality not taking
off it's been since the 80s right i
don't have strong opinions on it
on on the prospects of the technology i
personally i don't want to ever
imagine myself having something on my
eyes i'd rather just go out into the
real world
um but i don't have strong opinions on
virtual reality i do have one dabs and
nfts yeah what's your criticism of dabs
in nfts is this a distraction it's a way
to sell um a flawed uh technology the
problem with the apps is i mean it's
just the economics of it makes no sense
in the sense that um you know currently
um
if you wanted to run an application
whatever the application is
you want to run it on aws you pay a
specific amount of money you want to run
it on your own laptop you pay a specific
amount of money per kilobyte of data if
you wanted to run the same thing on a
distributed ledger where you're
distributing the data over thousands of
computers worldwide it's infinitely more
expensive and that's why we haven't seen
any of these dapps
take off and that's why i've said this
many years ago
the only working application of
blockchain technology is bitcoin because
with bitcoin you know you're with a few
hundred bytes of data with a few bytes
of data you could move a billion dollars
worth of
economic value from here to china
and move it safely and reliably so that
power
i i can't see it being justified for
anything that is not as mission critical
as moving large amounts of value which
require very little amount of
information so when you look at all of
the buzzwords that the ethereum and
other altcoin marketing people like to
use and you know
if you want to wonder really why we come
to this kind of aggression is because
we've heard all of this you know i've
had all these hucksters come to me for
years you know it's been i've had um you
know people in 2016 talk to me about how
um
ethereum blockchain technology is going
to revolutionize real estate deeds in
india now i remember this guy um
i
i'm not gonna mention his name
but this guy was you know 2016 and he
sold a lot of [ __ ] coins and he got made
a lot of money off of [ __ ] coins based
on the i based on all these silly ideas
we can have blackjack on a distributed
ledger we're going to have indian real
estate on a distributed ledger
and it's just it's concerned trolling
marketing you know oh there's a problem
with real estate
in india real estate deeds blockchain
fixes this buy my [ __ ] coin and then
people buy the [ __ ] coin
indian real estate isn't fixed and the
guy gets rich and they move on
but
i mean i'm still waiting for a dap to
actually emerge like
you know it's
the promise that we keep hearing is
something completely world changing
world transforming and the reality is
not one app like there's one of my good
friends jimmy song
eventually they refused to go ahead with
it but he wanted to bet with one of the
ethereum people
about uh about these daps you know the
ethereum people are constantly saying
those daps are going to grow and they're
going to have so many applications and
they're going to have so many ideas and
the reality is all the
apps that work are centralized apps you
know so there is no
uber on the blockchain there is no um
twitter on the blockchain there is no
social media on the blockchain because
these are businesses and businesses
require centralized authority to make
decisions you can't have it be
decentralized yeah listen you're
frustrated and i could see it over a few
years of just having dealt with a
humongous influx of charlatans i
wouldn't say frustrated i'm amused and
um
it's no
it's water off my back no but a man that
uses in a community they use the word
[ __ ] coin
is a little bit
you have you call it amusement and i
think amusement is the way
to deal
with the frustration it's a channel and
you have frustration like la sometimes
when you have to deal with [ __ ]
the best way is just to laugh at the
absurdity of it all and that's what you
mean by amusement
um but the the fact is like
there's things like artificial
intelligence for
uh what is it how many decades
seven decades has been
off and on promising to change
everything
and
it has failed time and time again to
deliver to the promise
but that doesn't mean there's something
fundamental and really powerful about
both the small and the big things going
on within the actual
research and development and within
those communities there's a lot of
exciting developments and the scale at
which those developments might actually
have a transformative impact the time
scale is unclear it seems like we all
certainly over promise we dream too big
and too aggressively in the ai community
but a lot of yeah and i'm happy to give
people the benefit of the doubt when
they're over promising but not when
they're making their own money when you
start making your own currency then you
don't get the benefit of the doubt
because if your idea needs you to have a
new currency that you print when bitcoin
is out there then i'm gonna go ahead and
assume that you're doing this for them
good time to mention that i i am
actually launching my
coin called lex coin you mean [ __ ] coin
yes
god
i'm gonna have to block you with love
you